>>> IT'S A TALE OF TWO THEORIES.
I'M MICHAEL SMERCONISH IN
PHILADELPHIA.
I'VE SPENT SEVERAL DAYS ON RADIO
THIS WEEK DISCUSSING THE LATEST
REVELATIONS CONCERNING THE
ORIGIN OF COVID-19.
AND A NUMBER OF CALLERS HAVE
ASKED A QUESTION THAT I FIND
ABSURD AND IT'S THIS -- WHO
CARES?
WHAT DOES IT MATTER WHETHER THE
VIRUS BEGAN BY JUMPING NATURALLY
FROM WILDLIFE TO PEOPLE OR
WHETHER IT ESCAPED FROM A LAB?
I HAVE A HUNCH AS TO WHY THEY
HAVE ASKED ME THAT.
IT'S POLITICAL.
THEY WORRY THAT IF THE ESCAPE
SCENARIO IS PROVEN, IT WILL BE A
WIN FOR THE OTHER TEAM.
SO THEY WOULD RATHER WE NOT ASK.
BUT RECENT DEVELOPMENTS, THEY
DEMAND ANSWERS.
THIS WEEK "THE WALL STREET
JOURNAL" BROKE THE STORY THAT
ACCORDING TO U.S. INTELLIGENCE,
IN NOVEMBER OF 2019, THREE
RESEARCHERS FROM CHINA'S WUHAN
INSTITUTE OF VIROLOGY WERE SICK
ENOUGH TO WARRANT HOSPITAL CARE.
IT WENT BEYOND WHAT THE STATE
DEPARTMENT HAD REVEALED IN THE
FINAL DAYS OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WHEN IT SAID THAT
SEVERAL RESEARCHERS CAME SICK
WITH SYMPTOMS CONSISTENT WITH
COVID.
NOVEMBER IS WHEN MANY BELIEVE
THE VIRUS BEGAN CIRCULATING
AROUND THE CITY OF WUHAN.
THE LATEST IN A SERIES OF
REVELATIONS THAT HAVE CAUSED
MANY WHO INITIALLY DISMISSED THE
LAB LEAK THEORY TO RECONSIDER.
AMONG THOSE IS DONNELL G. McNEIL
JR. A FORMER SCIENCE WRITER FOR
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WHO
RECENTLY PUBLISHED AN ESSAY
TITLED HOW I LEARNED TO STOP
WORRYING AND LOVE THE LAB LEAK
THEORY.
HE CREDITS A FORMER COLLEAGUE
FOR CAUSING HIS REFLECTION.
THAT FORMER COLLEAGUE IS
NICHOLAS WADE WHO, HIMSELF,
WROTE RECENTLY FOR THE BULLETIN
OF ATOMIC SCIENTISTS.
WADE DOES NOT COME TO A
CONCLUSION BUT SAYS NEITHER THE
NATURAL ESCAPE THEORY NOR THE
NATURAL EMERGENCE HYPOTHESIS CAN
BE RULED OUT.
HE NOTED THIS.
BECAUSE PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID THE
VIRUS WILL ESCAPED FROM A WUHAN
LAB, EDITORS GAVE THE IDEA
LITTLE CREDITENCE AND JOINED THE
VIROLOGISTS.
QUOTE.
FACEBOOK EVEN WENT SO FAR AS TO
BAN POSTS SAYING THAT COVID-19
WAS MAN-MADE OR MANUFACTURED AND
REVERSED THAT POLICY THIS WEEK.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SHUT DOWN A
STATE DEPARTMENT INVESTIGATION
WHETHER THE VIRUS COULD HAVE
LEAKED FROM A CHINESE LAB USING
INEFFECTIVE RESOURCES.
ON WEDNESDAY, BIDEN CHANGED
COURSE ORDERING INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIALS TO REINVESTIGATE THE
ORIGINS OF COVID AND REPORT BACK
TO HIM WITHIN 90 DAYS.
BUT HOW MANY WILL BE READY TO
LISTEN WHEN WE GET THOSE
RESULTS?
SADLY, THE ORIGIN OF COVID-19
HAS BECOME YET ANOTHER OF THOSE
ISSUES WHERE WE SUIT UP IN OUR
PARTISAN ARMOR BEFORE WE HAVE
ALL OF THE FACTS.
TRUMP SAID X, I'LL SAY Y.
TRUMP BELIEVED THE ESCAPE THEORY
THAT I'M GOING WITH AN
ALTERNATIVE EXPLANATION THEN.
THE NATURAL PROGRESSION OF THIS
THINKING AMONG SOME IS TO NOT
WANT THERE TO BE ANY ANSWER OF
ANY KIND, BECAUSE IT MIGHT
CONFLICT WITH THEIR
PREDETERMINED VIEWS.
CASE IN POINT, THIS CALLER ON MY
SIRIUS XM RADIO PROGRAM.
>> >> Caller: WHAT DIFFERENCE
DOES IT MAKE IF THE SPANISH FLU
WE FIND OUT IT DIDN'T START IN
SPAIN AND MAYBE STARTED IN FT.
RILEY, KANSAS?
WHAT DIFFERENCE DOES IT MAKE?
I FRANKLY DON'T CARE.
WHAT I CARE HOW DO WE PREVENT IT
FROM HAPPENING IN THE FUTURE?
>> HE MAY NOT CARE BUT I DO.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT VIRUS THAT
HAS KILLED 3.5 MILLION PEOPLE
WORLDWIDE OF PARAMOUNT CONCERN
IS PREVENTING IT FROM HAPPENING
AGAIN.
IF THIS RESULTED FROM SO-CALLED
GAIN OF FUNCTION RESEARCH THEN
WHETHER SUCH EXPERIMENTATION
SHOULD CONTINUE HAS TO BE
CONSIDERED.
SO TOO THE FUNDING.
IF THE CHINESE WERE NEGLIGENT
AND/OR GAUG ENG